les groupes parlementaires de gauche à
l'assemblée ont déposé un recours devant
le conseil constitutionnel sur ce texte
qu'est ce que vous allez faire au sénat
est ce que vous y réfléchissez donc ça
s'est fait hier soir et donc nous avons
prévu d'échanger moins pour le parti dit
guillaume pour le groupe au sénat et
allié fort donc nous allons dans les
prochaines heures pour une décision
commune donc on a donc comme vous l'avez
dit ça a été adopté par l'assemblée donc
ils ont annoncé cela en lien avec nous
et puis là on va travailler ensemble
naissait ne groupe
d'ailleurs je j'associe également le
groupe des parlementaires européens nous
sommes 120 parlementaires
nous sommes la première force de gauche
d'opposition à ce pouvoir est à la
droite avec vos pieds qui vient d'être
installé
et donc nous travaillons ensemble moi je
verrai ce que nous travaillons ensemble
sur les prises de position ce que nous
faisons est ce que nous allons faire